(peaceful music)
- [Narrator] A two-hour boat
ride off the coast of Colombia
is an island, the most
densely-populated island on earth.
(chattering)
Santa Cruz del Islote consists
of more than 1,200 people
living on land the size
of two soccer fields,
making it four times
as dense as Manhattan.
On the island is a school
that runs up to the 10th grade,
two shops, and one restaurant.
There is no steady supply of water
and a sole generator that only
runs for five hours per day.
There are no police, but there
isn't much need for them,
as everyone on the
island knows each other.
(children chattering)
150 years ago, the island
was primarily uninhabited
and was sometimes used by local fishermen
as a place to rest and
take shelter during storms.
Gradually, some fishermen came
to build their homes here.
These were the grandparents
and great-grandparents
of the current generation of residents.
Despite the close living quarters,
inhabitants on the island
say they wouldn't give up
their peaceful existence for anything,
not even a little more room.
(chattering)
(peaceful jingling)